imagine if the new york jets had a
public vote on who they were going to go
after in free agency a couple weeks ago
and that was public domain that would
have hurt them well gary
doesn't matter what the jets do we can't
hold on hold on this could blow up real
fast right now
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
evan preston great to see you guys hope
you're well uh super excited about our
collaboration and
uh the innovations we're doing in sports
uh for the people that don't know you
guys you want to give yourselves a
little intro here
preston while you go ahead you're more
exciting than i am
i don't know about that look my
background is somewhat in sports i was a
sports bettor for about a decade and
then i was a tv analyst on espn for a
few years and then actually left to
prioritize web3 last year in march um
and started pixel vault with the punk's
comic project with sean gierin and gary
thank you i know you were supportive of
me from the get-go there so just
appreciative to be here extremely lucky
and excited that uh we get to talk to
you a little bit awesome yeah my name is
evan smith i was a former options trader
lost the licensing battle around nba top
shot got into nfts pretty early
and just kind of back again with the
past year and see a lot of stuff to
build and really excited about it
what's the most exciting part
of this project from your perspective
for me it's that you know we've seen all
of these communities gather that are
digitally native first around
intellectual property around community
storytelling
and
there's all this excitement and often it
feels like
you know it's without the spine of a
story it's really it's amazing that it's
happened
without the story already pre-told but
with sports you have season after season
where you have a game every saturday to
gather around a team to follow you know
from from starting with a
team in the fourth division we have a
place to go it's a natural goal it's
just um it should be really exciting to
take all the
parts that have worked so far and try to
apply it to a sports franchise
press
yeah to go a step further i mean people
have been talking about it online for
seven eight months like hey we should
buy a sports team or do something right
in just the crypto web 3 space as a
whole
i'm excited about actually trying to do
that right like we got this club we want
to bring it to the people and they can
help us via digital first community
stuff build it into something that's
great that actually has a chance because
i mean you've done a great job of
e-friends by the way of actually
bringing utility and what evan's
alluding to 99 out there to say hey you
might have a hoodie one day or a
character into central land like we have
a sports club right we have a team
let's let's build from there and so i
think i think it's everyone's pretty
excited because they've been asking for
this anyway and we've been able to kind
of deliver at least so far yeah yeah
gary i would actually be interested in
what you have to say but to me it's like
it's a blank space and figuring out what
it means to have a digitally native
community-owned sports team right that's
exactly what it is it's not i mean for
me for me it's a clean canvas around an
interest graph that i'm obsessed with
that
can tap into new technologies
to create new outcomes
yeah 100
you know this team um has been bound by
its region for 126 years and they've
they've gotten as high as league one and
there's uh there's really no pathway for
them to grow beyond that if
if they go the old-fashioned way but we
have the ability to try to
find fans from all over the world with a
new branding and with a new approach and
if we're successful at that we're just
going to have a
much larger growth opportunity than the
rest of the teams around us and that
should should lead to outsized outcomes
which will hopefully attract more fans i
mean that's really what we're trying to
do
when when your friends
in real life
hear
a whiff of this and they're like wait
wait what are you doing because i wanted
a lot of people to hear this what um
how do you answer them
preston sure i mean
that's actually most people just think
it's really cool because i was like oh
that's always the dream when you're a
kid
how do you actually explain it to them
press like mundane like button from
around the way he's like breast did i
just see your name on this what is
what's going on go i i basically tell
them i'll say hey we have this club in
crawleytown it's near london it's great
proximity there we're excited about the
prospects of the efl and potentially
moving up
a proper football team yeah we're
bringing the internet a team and now we
have a chance to attach all of these
fans across the internet across the
world to this club that's local near
london
that's what we're doing if you want to
be involved like we'll talk more about
the details you don't even need to get
nfts or web3 it's sports and look sports
fans they're communities as is anyway
like we're just doing that but we're
doing it for the internet
i i say that we're doing kind of a real
life lasso
where we're buying a sports team and
we're trying to bring an outsized
audience to it and if we're successful
we're going to we're going to move up
and it's going to get crazier from here
i say it's the adventure when you when
you say move up to americans they don't
know what you mean
yeah you have to start by explaining
promotion relegation which is the whole
reason we're starting over there as
opposed to over here you we have an
entry ticket to the highest league in
the world even if we're not in that
league right now this would be like if
you bought the hudson valley renegades
the single a baseball team and then had
a plan to become the yankees right it
seems it seems impossible here because
you're not allowed to do it i mean god
would the nba be a better product if
they had promotion of relegation but
that's a story for a different day uh
you know like there's no tanking over
there you tank you go down so it's a
purely capitalist
uh structure whereas over here it's
actually quite socialist in the way that
we approach sports where it's a club and
you can't get out of the club once
you're in
so that's what makes it so exciting to
me
[Music]